direct your videos
somehow should be aspiring towards
emotionally satisfied foreign
foreign
so they don't mind for the graves to be
washed besides Allah
maybe they don't know it they haven't
realized the danger of shook they don't
mind the Empire to come okay and as long
as they do it no problem you see but no
woman naked
yeah
what's happening you know but the point
here is which one is better to have a
Muslim country that is and they have
some mistakes or a country that they
have no dancing of remixing but shook is
open
what do you think
something wishing is
something which is what you must have
had what do you think that we need it or
we don't need that or of course we need
to hate of course no yeah disagree with
you
but is it something we should be working
towards no no doubt about that but you
walk towards your house
how you towards it
So when you say that
is
Empire
so if our main targets
are pagans for the leadership
how do you believe
so much
yeah and they spread it and Allah
is the best example Saudis never started
militias Saudi was
there was a tribe in yeah
and he wants to tell the leader he said
he was leading the area on behalf of
Richmond Empire foreign
I hate him and I love you
so this lcr's family they were really
small tiny bit of the Arab peninsula
when they started to call after heat
that's not only the whole other place
they're the biggest other country in
Africa
is to have started likewise
Uganda you know many have not many
African Brothers they don't know about
the the moravity
11 20. Nigeria no it's not nice
who was sent by uh was named al-face
from Susa in Indonesia so they went and
debuted Maracas that's now kamuroko but
the point here is
if you see him he said this guy was a
black man he was a selfie Warrior who
spread
but right now
in Africa
even I got some Muslims
there were some Muslims they believed
that it's okay to have intercourse with
your with the with the wife's neighbor
because I'm making hello
even though he believed they believed in
my area
victory
do you think this is problematic it is
because historically speaking many
people that try to do that they tell the
way from Islam completely
you have to sell your deed to be part of
the government I was asking because a
lot of people have had to say that I
Professor who is Parliament it's perfect
all right so we used to enjoy the the
league be careful but what do you think
that you think that who said that is
Instagram
so this is a young man oh someone told
me
Muslim
and he said that's the message before so
I said okay come live with us he came
left and he went off yeah then he said
okay can we do a private I said no
problem I gave him my number he
contacted me he's out my friend with me
so I said no problem
we have a rabbi yeah there were two of
them in WhatsApp yeah he said there's a
rabbi he will speak to you I said he
said I need to go to work out that and
it was like on the Tempe 11 pm yeah so
as a team look bro I said no problem
maybe they were recorded me the guy he's
scared now he's alive I said let me call
them back I'll call them back then I had
this guy saying a student of
um
can you stop your donkey man I was
getting rooted because because he
was you know I do did you put the Jew
now yeah
and he's a Muslim but one of them
contacted me because I said in Western I
said you know you became careful
against Islam
you know I said no problem I forgive you
you know regardless I said I forgive you
you know I said but you have to make it
over the frontier is look how crazy it
is Young Brothers
I don't care bro I'm going to call you
back but the point here is
too much with the young people online
I don't know
how do I know that you can't even know
that you cannot increase the good and
decrease the evil but now by default if
you join like this uh the mayor of
London nothing
of course
even there is a guy he was a school of
knowledge
he became he got involvement Politics
the Pope
politics
people politics
study
I said if you want to sit with a lion
sit with politicians
generally speaking politicians
the person chosen how many life
you know you lost you lost count how
many times you lied that's how bad it is
right not so I can study politics
policy politics is not the reason why
people are being oppressed with Society
while there's a lot of corruption it
doesn't need to be awake and understand
all these things it's good that we
understand
because they don't understand how the
politicians are playing the political
game to use Muslims
do you understand
yeah I break it down very easily
British politics
for example
look how they made you believe when you
of course they're giving you your right
to project your your opinion your
opinion no they manipulating you how
they manipulate you these parties around
the world in America and Canada and
Britain that's every party this party is
who's behind them lobbyists and so on
yeah big big organizations they look at
which party is going
to fulfill their agenda so what are they
gonna do they're gonna use a big money
to to create a big campaign to affect
people's opinions so you thinking you're
free but you don't know that you've been
affected by the social media and other
things so democracy is hypocrisy you
understand so the point here is that
that's a simple way I don't understand
the politics in details to know politics
based upon democracy and this emotional
not Russian no Russian music almost no
quick that's why Islam comes in what we
have we don't have voting we have a
Surah I know everything everything
person no it's College
righteous people they're the people of
power they come and choose a leader and
remember when they choose the leaders
of course they can become corrupt no
doubt about that oh the checks and
balances
to deal with the issue
people at the topic
Allah will never let us down because
Allah
if they become corrupt others could
expose them what do you think they are
today
through all these people today yeah
I believe it's one of them yes
Jonathan Brown oh I'm asking who are the
people who are you know
yeah
of course and they tell you how to deal
with it not if the if the leader becomes
corrupted what is the correct way to
deal with it is
well
with the prayer
likewise because after four should
accept it okay you know when when the
leader become a captain
to the world
Authority the school is to go back to
they decide if it's the best time to go
shot huh
is the leaders
yes
no because Islam comes with what as
ibruary Islam and as the Calamity of
young Brothers go online
there's a Calamity listen to this yeah
Islam comes to increase goodness and
decrease the evil to bring about the
goodness and to remove away evil in the
sense if I know about rebellion against
this disbeliever leader leader is going
to cause a greater harm
for the same cause
no some for democracy some for a
liberalism some for socialism
for Islam and all of them you understand
that's why if you're gonna remove
you have to make sure you have a good
leader don't destroy a city for the sake
of within the house but what I'm saying
is that when you say be patients what
I'm saying is if the person is
impeaching upon your own rights to the
rights of your wife
said what extent like for example now if
it comes to rape your family you have to
fight all of that you have to fight if
they kill yourself yeah of course Amelia
talk about your family he said you don't
pray you disobey him you don't listen to
it
doesn't have to come to my house if he
says to me
don't pay us I don't listen to you
that but that should not be a leeway for
me to cause Rebellion
understand you mean with arms
arms
or
something's decision how he divided
wealth yes
foreign
or you're gonna get the mistakes of the
leader what are you bringing you're not
bringing okay you're just causing a
great time
it seems to be something
if there is no yeah
no no it's different between speaking
about the leader himself I bet you say
in this series
yeah and let me make something clear as
well very important to understand
sometimes the leader can be a good
leader and he can oppress sometimes more
doesn't mean because he's good he has to
be perfect but maybe he did it based
upon the wrong information or for that
he did not put some school of Islam in
prison he did why because baseball Porn
first information was given to him so
he's a great leader foreign
does this fall into condemnation or does
this fall against uh foreign
to decrease you know a lot of people to
understand so if you just do it for the
sake of doing it what is the point for
example people there in this in Britain
America speaking about problems has
happened Algeria or Morocco Saudi what
is the objective called America has a
bigger issues Egypt
brother these brothers
has a big problem with his own family
I'll just start practicing I don't even
know how to pray correctly you tell him
were you telling me
I have my own struggles you said how do
you think he's from Islam
what you just described yes
I don't think it's an Italian dinner
when he wants to speak about some issues
about the leaders he will not speak to
the Layman because the Layman cannot
understand it properly yeah that's why
when people started
became a leader you know he was not
leader
he said yeah don't do it here because
people don't misunderstand you you go
back to Medina when you have the sahaba
there don't understand you correctly
your own room
your own room is dirty you want to go
clean the Saudi
clean your own room first then clean
your living room as well be generous
help your mouth then go clean Saudi then
another before Saudi push Market first
you understand that's the reality
but what is our problem now as you we
want to see ourselves and the season
we're doing and once you have these guys
must know nothing these guys
I believe is a setup
your mother is a fornicator
Allah imagine he will shut it off this
guy is
the first person
is
you know he called the other brothers
foreign
every person
brother okay he always after colleges
yeah okay
every country
majority populations
is a Muslim country but
like there's majority of Muslims
so I'm saying this is
there is fasted there is so what is it
is
only cut off the hands
Iran Implement that is the country
so that's why it's a Muslim countries
why would you say that it's normal
country why because
of course the government like in their
three other people by the government but
if the government Muslim and also Islam
is well established established
again
but even that
foreign
if you believe in the summer stuff he
goes look the reason that we as a
Muslims were in this mess you know why
people chat with Allah
you have these Machining people they
won't share it actually up and we will
explain
and I've noticed people
dude
or they are criminals
stated not to bring hardship upon the
human beings to save human beings from
the other human beings who are criminals
and they want to cause corruption upon
the Earth so why our problem would
accept your ignorant Oreo Criminal
that's the conclusion of it
and you know the taxis
exposing us he believes
you understand because you know about
speaking to one of the video guy they
talk about it out of context
I mean in this country because
in a country that use of you live in a
council house you serve your control by
the government how are you gonna rule
Yes master
Khalifa however
and the hater for the sake of Allah it
said those are ignorant they don't know
we teach them he said I'm a Khalifa in
Islam
who he lives you know where he lives in
the council state
is
yeah
I don't know what happened to him like
one of them I know one of them happened
to me the small Bridge or five
with the brothers who just are
practicing yeah 206 yeah so they said
these guys Khalifa you know he smokes
is a clown
why is this joke man it's embarrassment
you make an instant look bad
how are you coming to country are they
coming as a refugee oh your family came
here you're born here they're giving
your passport okay how are you coming
today I'm going to take over your
country imagine bringing you to my house
I allow you to sit in my house the next
time I say over
oh you're gonna show me your good
character and maybe like what the
Muslims did sahaba did with najashi
and the characteristics
are the best friends
will lie
and they don't like to see the Muslim
country stable
you Aspire for a person
no maybe tomorrow I would love for
tomorrow
I forgot about a long time I would love
this country to become the majority of
people don't I'm not Muslim it wouldn't
work out if the government we just tried
to take it I forgot about the government
my main course I would love to come from
the people to become Muslims
why
sincerity he doesn't want leadership he
doesn't want to see he wants to be
guided
going to the people of power not because
you want to get the leadership but the
person is powerful like just like back
in the day one leader became
Muslims about that but if he rejects
what you're gonna do so I speak about
him day and night move on move on
foreign
directly
understand of course I'm gonna kill you
it's a nice respect but you don't have
to start you know chasing them
yeah no dogs
so who's the points what about saying
you know obviously you're not supposed
to go swimming to someone come on that's
not what I'm saying that you should go
and kill him what I'm saying is you how
Muslim you succeed he said if not then
we're going to be on our way
and that's only it can only be here
something right now yeah
the way you know since
how Jihad
even but the thing is right now if
people were to do something like that
right now
no no but first you have to understand
why why she had a problem
to free the people
speaks about in the job he said Jihad is
Jihad Minister that's safe is preaching
yes Jihad obviously it was legislated to
remove the tyrants yeah to the people
because why there's two types of people
there's people who has the truth and the
people who wants to hear the truth and
the people that they don't want to hear
the truth and they want to prevent the
truth to be convey majority of time
those who are in power
anymore
politics
because
look
in this country yes
Allah is
give us a blessing in this country
freedom
freedom to preach to preach yes they
don't trouble you especially in Britain
accomplished many times
doesn't mean you're gonna agree with
everything they do no but if they gave
you something be grateful understand
like what I don't like that you're
coming from a country your country
you're going away from a single world
then they have you here they cannot you
a Visa they help your family then you
tell the ways I'm coming over the
country you make yourself look bad oh
God your own country is you you you you
you all people are dying in the city to
come to Europe foreign
openly
we should appreciate that you come like
one of the they said yes they say about
our schools
foreign governments
Supreme Courts but hold a minute Supreme
Court the European capitalists it's okay
for you yeah
the other one he really wants America
he's openly I was working I'm a five
give money to give you give it to
everyone
they will accuse you of something while
they are doing it why because they want
to remove what
the focus focus and the heat from them
the heat from them you understand
publication taking money
I heard this guy the government's after
him
because they keep changing from one
organization another organization and
they say that is a sign for what
fraud yeah yes
so these guys he said openly I was
working for mfi America said we don't
care it's in Britain you're American now
and he was getting money from the the
government
the other one is
do you think there's people in this park
some people some people in Spanish
foreign foreign
exactly